[Music]
you know there's like I even buy almost
Lynette no need to be here open it to go
yeah describe the day you live to a
place of birth I was born in st. Mary's
Parish and not to obey in Jamaica
hissarlik I remember is I know it's a
beautiful country like hot palm trees
everything in but last time I was there
was four years old so what about you eh
was horrible I couldn't say goodbye to
my mom I just had to tell her to walk
down like this just because Isis
couldn't see her so when I sleep
sometimes I keep pretty Mambo saying the
same thing Wow not being able to say bye
to you more than that what is your
biggest miss come mr. Khan
misconceptions about Britain's yeah
where I grew up in North London back
then in the 80s there was like National
Front and BMP and stuff like that and
getting called all sorts of things like
even in school you know you black this
you black that and go you know f off
back to my own country and once or twice
I felt like a bit didn't want to be this
color because of the way I was getting
treated but then I just fought like I
just fought now so I stand and stand up
strong for this colour and be proud of
my colour and be proud of where I'm from
and and everything but yeah I felt
discriminated through my colour but I
feel a bit let down by Britain over
country that I've been in for 41 years
though longer than I've been in Jamaica
and I've done many many things for to
represent for England the UK and I still
feel that I've been treated and
discriminate in a way because of my
color what about yourself when I first
heard after the country I didn't speak
English as good as I do right now
so I joined the college I don't know how
long I'm here for as long as I'm here
for I wanted to make some friend where I
could feel that I belong to I had one
friend over at my flat and on he just
start saying you should [ __ ] off to your
country Wow don't start throw stuff at
me like this like I came on I am from
Syria I know you may be a bit scared but
I can't have you in my house you have
just been so racist to me and I'm
beautiful yeah you know so he just said
[ __ ] off to your country done I can't
say it's a brilliant is great
everybody's lovely snow and it's not bad
a little pointer if you walk on the
street everybody doesn't like you know
these people who like see the people who
want to chat with you but you still feel
that the judgement that the weird look
that people look at you when you walk
into a bar into a cafe and its life you
had to deal with that when people are
ignorant towards you do you have some
form of Defense where you can handle it
better deal with it I just keep walking
I don't know ignore those because if you
start something these people want to you
too you know if if someone walk at you
and and say something they want you to
start to fight that and the same if I
was to respond react to every person
that was ignorant towards me I just flip
it back on him with a smile ignore him
but with him but would kind this man get
it describe your first day in the UK a
dream
I was happy the point that my parents
didn't believe that I'm gonna do okay
for me it was different so I've come
into the UK at four years old that I'm
seeing different colored people so I'm
like oh wow and brick houses and and
like the roads and everything and can it
wasn't sunny as well it was cold as far
as cold as hurry it was cold it's cold
yeah what's a common misconception of
immigration some people think that
immigration is a bad subject is a bad
people you know stay away from them
these people are dangerous I think two
months ago some boats crossed the
channel English Channel from France to
England and there was in the news life
saying those people are coming to our
country why don't you say oh these
people are coming here and is so
dangerous why don't we make it safer for
Dennis oh yeah I have been on a boat on
a sea story
Stockton DC for seven hours no one knows
what I'm gonna do
calling the police degree said you want
and take this border we can't do
anything under Turkish they say the same
island Intl water nobody will do
anything for you just leave you there
I said talk for six seven hours I don't
know what to do we were like seventy
five people on the boat can't fit more
than thirty percent
I'm not the person who came here to do
something bad to you I haven't had the
choice if I had the choice I would live
in my country I would stay there I was a
student at the University everything was
good for me I had a life my family my
my mom my sibling all of everybody's
around me I had friends why would I
choose to leave all this love that I had
a man come to a way to somewhere that I
don't know anybody it's just something
that you have to deal with where you
didn't plan for it
it doesn't make you bad person watch you
know so for me like my mom had the
opportunity to come over to England to
the UK to get a better life not only for
herself but for me and my sister they
don't understand that we're just trying
to come over here to get there trying to
live a better life than what we're
having in our own country because things
have been taken away from us and stuff
so the only way you get to know is if
you speak to someone and actually find
out okay describe British food in two
words
fish and chips yeah that's free okay
do you find it easy to talk about your
experience what when I'm speaking about
my experience I'll get a bit who clogged
up emotional about it I've done 95
percent positive stuff and because I've
done a negative thing I got held in
detention when I got checked into the
detention center I was on the phone to
my lawyer I had a big crush a big thud
it was a guy who would put a sheet
around his neck and he throwing himself
off the third floor and I was still on
the phone to my lawyer at that time and
I don't know like you hear about things
you know I hope the guy I hope the guy I
shout it to two guys underneath hold him
up hold him up so if they didn't hold
him up I would have had to pull on the
sheet to be able to loosen it and not
many people know they experienced some
detention centres your point in prison X
close down buildings X prisons X women's
men's prisons I got held well ya held in
detention for a period of about four or
five months then I got put on
immigration bail but when you want
immigration bail you can't work you
basically can't do anything so if I was
to be in an accident I was admitted to
hospital they wouldn't give me no
treatment when I first arrived to the
country I have 35 pound a week oh that's
what you get when seeking asylum yeah
that's what they give you you have to
buy you know like top up your phone by
protect for to wash your clothes by food
so I was filled up with energy where I
wanted to speak English and then go out
and talk to people and make friends and
I had this you know beautiful life I'm
gonna do I'm gonna make my dreams happen
and again I'm gonna study I'm gonna walk
I'm gonna make a life so I went to the
college and they said you weren't
allowed to study after six months of
being in the country I thought to myself
what can I do if six months okay I can
go out and find a job and um practice my
English I didn't know I'm not allowed to
work because I can't speak English so I
went back home and I'm I said between
four walls I can't do nothing that is my
experience that's why I got revised what
it feels like one of the guys Daniel
killed himself he doesn't know what's
going on he doesn't know when he went to
get his statement he can't walk he can't
study he can't do anything he just sit
down and the house he can't even go out
and talk to people you know he doesn't
have the language send the message to
his sisters and say I'm gonna kill
myself they come back home they found
him dad that's how sad it is that's how
dangerous it is you know I thought well
if I spoke about my experience and let
the people know what is going on
it might help somebody's life and I
think it's very important do you talk
about your experience there
next question yeah that was a that was a
deep question that wall was that any
move that was you know I said yeah right
how's the UK become more hostile to live
in I live with the family I with English
couple who hosted me I'm really thankful
for them you know they make me feel like
I am home which is really important for
me you know people says immigration or
refugees don't give us anything they
just take from me but if you think for
further in the future they would join
the NHS doctors they might be a fast
driver he might take from them the home
but also I'm giving them something but
I've been here for 41 years I'm on the
immigration bill I can't work I've got
free children I've just launched
well yeah launched label a music label
called stand up speak out which is for
the voiceless and it's basically
encouraging individuals whether they've
been through experiences like ourselves
or they've going through some mental
health issues or drug use issues that
they can use this platform to basically
get their voices heard via music so I
walk with music which is a business we
started me and my friend it was really
it was a night time and we were asleep
in Cali in the jungle and then we saw
the ferry now this phase going to
England my friend climbed off and jumped
easily and on when I climbed up
everybody hurts and they have everybody
here can't move my leg so my I said to
my friend run run away and I said no no
we're gonna make it all together I was
like if we can't make it all together he
put me in his back and he started
running while he's running my leg is
moving when it's moving it was
thankfully when I stayed for tonight
where the broken day the doctor come the
end from the jungle they deal with their
to put some plastic and some plaster
around there and they said you come for
six weeks my friend he was like okay we
cannot cook something to eat
and we start to make food we ended
making it together to the UK and then we
ended as a quad we don't make the same
food that we had in care that we start
to say that over here everybody says
together share the food and share story
if you know talk to other people made a
lot of friends you know it is beautiful
when you see someone who is welcoming
you for no reason has just made the food
made by love it didn't you didn't plant
to be a chef you didn't plant to do to
just make it like Sebastian sitting up
young last weekend it was the no yeah
last weekend was the first University of
the business Oh calm down for somebody
welcome thank you
[Music]
you